comment qu'il fallait pas louper avec la
mère de Paris
annidalgo elle a encore taclé Rachida
Dati après sa nomination au ministère de
la Culture est tellement jalouse oh là
là alle est jalou celle-ci oh regardez
c'était sur France 2 regardez France 2
est-ce que c'est vrai que vous avez
éclaté de rire quand vous avez appris
qu'elle était nommé ministre de la
Culture je sais pas si j'ai éclaté de
rire mais j'ai vraiment très sincèrement
pensé au monde de la culture après vous
savez je vais vous dire d'abord qu'elle
fasse ses preuvees hein que chacun fasse
ses preuves et on juge les gens sur les
actes et la deuxième chose peu
égoïstement pour moi en tant que maire
de Paris
dans cet hémicycle du Conseil de Paris
on a quand même vécu des épreuves hein
pendant 3 années de d'injure d'insultte
permanent bah vous savez quoi ça va nous
faire un peu des vacances et ça ça me
réjouit plutôt il y a un petit côté bon
des Baras pour vous au niveau du en tout
les cas je suis plutôt contente vouses
plutôt contente ah ouais ouais c'est fou
hein ouais franchement c'est ta copine
ça c'est c'est pas ma copine mais c'est
ta copine ta copine arrête un peu ce
n'est pas ma copine copine commence pas
à 19h22 c'est pas ma copine mais mais
quelle honte de dire ça non c'est
sensé j'aimerais avir j'aimerais avoir
un dalmatien s'il vous plaît donc déjà
moi je trouve qu'elle méprise rachidti
il y a une sorte de délit comme ça genre
elle la délégitime en en tant que
ministre de la Culture mais pourquoi en
fait sur quelle base j'ai ri
dit pourquoi on parle jamais du bilan de
Rachida Dati comme R ou comme Gard des
SA ou quand elle était magistrate
pourquoi en fait c'est juste parce
qu'elle s'appelle Rach ça pose un
problème à Madame Idalgo et je trouve
que ça c'est absolument dégueulasse en
fait on dit pas qu'elle est enfin elle
dit à la base en fait elle dit elle
n'est pas compétente pour la culture
mais en fait sur quelle base en fait
c'est quoi pour être compétente pour la
culture par par ailleurs elle parle
d'insulte et cetera ça veut dire que
pour elle le débat politique c'est ce
sont des insultes non c'était une
opposante politique elles se sont opposé
mais il s'agit elle a dit qu'elle
s'inquiétait pour le monde de la culture
elle ferait mieux s'inquiéter pour les
Parisiens parce que je pense qu' y a
plus a plus d'inquiétude à avoir pour
les Parisiens que pour le monde de la
culture
alors et je te le dis hein c'est pas un
débat tu parleras pas sur cette SC à
propos du mondeure vous avez vu quand il
y a eu la passation là AB elle elle n'a
rien laissé à rachti dans son bureau C
dans Paris Match normalement quand il y
a une passation de pouvoir on laisse les
dossiers il a y a le a le en fait avait
même pas un
st un Doss il y avait rien non mais vous
imaginez l'esprit en fait Abd mal je
sais on parle d'elle je sais a priori o
va aller ah ou peut pas le direon on va
en être débarrassé euh
loinisque pas de la croiser très souvent
je vous dis non les Médi dans les médias
non non ambassade loine dans les médias
c'est bon si c'est vos amis bah vous
savez où sont merci moi j'ai un conseil
pour tous les Français qu'est-ce qu'elle
a non mais j'ai un conseil bah déjà vous
chez à mon avis vous avez vous avez pas
tellement de lumière chez vous par que
non mais c'est un conseil important
parce qu'en fait du coup vu qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui apprécient pas
anidalgo il faudra changer de M et par
exemple il y a un truc faut faut y
penser moi quand je suis allé voter et
ben j'ai fait la queue pour voter j'ai
attendu 1h3 tout ça tout ça et une fois
devant la dame pour voter elle m'a
demandé est-ce que je suis éta inscr
inscrite à la liste j'ai demandé bah
quelle liste et du coup j'ai pas pu
voter du coup pour voter pour il faut
être inscrit à la liste dire tuas raison
bravo non mais tu vois c'est con parce
qu'on y pense pas
mais vous allez voir qu'elle va se
représenterir des cons
comm le mode de scru le mode de scrutin
va changer à Paris le président de la
République l'a annoncé on votera pour le
maire
pass gag
pas
plus
systmei ce mot
démocratie pour qu'il se taise mais
qu'il soit payé mais qu'il se taise et
en plus faut choisir c'est Mo qu' est en
politique ça va nous faire les vacances
pour quelqu'un qui revien 3 semaines de
Tahiti je c c'est vrai bravo
[Applaudissements]
a bossé a
bossé là il a bossé là il a bossé làz
qu' veut là il a lu entrevue qu' veut
voulez que je vous explique ce qui va se
passer en 2026 aux prochaines élections
municipales à Paris les Jeux Olympiques
vous êtes écoute-moi bien alors
écoute-moi bien tu sais quoi non mais
écoute-moi je terer ma phrase ou je
t'expliquer juste quelque chose avant
que tu parles ce que va dire ce garsl
les gars il connait rien n rien c'est
comme la dernière fois quand il nous a
dit que ça allait passer l'autoroute là
V sur le périf à 50 kmh il n connait
rien d' rien parce que j'ai eu le
ministre des transport qui m'a dit que
vous disiez d'énormes conneries ou ou ou
disiez d'énormes conneries donc je vous
dis j'ai même eu le nouveau voilà et il
a aussi dit que je disais d'énormes
conneries qui ça n min ou le nouveau
ministre de transport Vin
Diesel
je te le dis donc voilà je te le dis
voilà donc non mais vas-y dis ta
connerie et après vous j'aimerais vous
vous vous tourniez vers moi et je vous
dirai la vérité puisquil va dire encore
sa connerie qu'estce qui va se passer en
2026 vous êtes
prêtentendre merci allez place au place
place à Guignol
merci merci
beaucoup le spectacle je pas dis pas que
vous étiez un guignolle mais c'est le
spectacle ah pardonectac guign les jeux
olympiques à Paris vont être un triomphe
du 26 6 juillet 11 août toi team ferme
ta gueule parce que le chur
de vu ce qu'il a pris dans la gueule
hier il a pas moué si j'étais toi une
semaine je me tais voilà oui déjà c'est
bon là je
[Musique]
su je ne suis pas
complètement merci tu veux qu'on appelle
Pénélope fais gaffe alors oui donc donc
déjà alors première connerie donc déjà
je vais noter tu sais quoi je vais noter
en une phrase combien tu dis de
conneries merci j'ai un stylo j'ai un
quatre couleur tiens je vais noter tu
peux savoir ça va être un grand succès
attendsssendsends donc les Jeux
Olympiques vont être un sucès avec
anidalgo merci donc annidalgo sort sur
ce triomphe d'accord ouais freine non
non elle SF à Tahiti elle sfent pas sur
ce freine son premier acjoint monieur
Grég sur par roule pas merci freine les
ambitions freine à Paris parce qu'on
roule pas merci par y a beaucoup [__]
donc stop totalement monsieur Grégoire
son premier adjoint qui veut le job et
elle va triomfer gr il est plus sympa
j'aime bien moi elle va triompher de
rachidti puisque à chaque fois qu'un
candidat a été nommé par le pouvoir
macroniste et la droite à Paris c'est
une catastrophe
totale tu sa comme Fatou je peux te dire
qu'elle pas chance de baladercoute bien
pour un mec qui n'a jamais rien réussi
tu as beaucoup de de certitude
excuse-moi mon chéri voilà t'aim bien
pass au du poste le président Emmanuel
Macron quelques soucis pendant ses
discours le 5 janvier pendant la galette
des RO il y a eu un petit malaise mais
heureusement le président a les bons
conseils il nous rappelle un peu un
fameux médecin d'une série américaine
regarde et nous allons demander aux
fournisseurs de les renégocier et de le
faire je pense qu'il faut que vous
aidiez ce jeune homme alors ouvrez les
fenêtres ça arrive quand on a prenez un
un bol d'air à mon avis un sucre aussi
et on arrive ça c'est des jeunes qui
prennent pas le petit déj oui c'est
possible je vous le
[Applaudissements]
dis
alors problème c'est que j'ai
l'impression que dès qu'il arrive
quelque part le président en ce moment
il y a des gens qui font des malaises
quelques jours après le 2 19 janvier
lors des vux aux forces armées encore un
malaise pendant le discours du président
regardez à Paris à Marseille en
Polynésie et nous le
savons je pense qu'il faut
aider je m'interrompre pour qu'il puisse
y avoir une intervention je vous rassure
c'est un malaise vagal ça ne devrait pas
être grave
[Applaudissements]
jours après nouveau discours de monde
sportif nveau malaise jamais 203
toujours pas de stress pour Emmanuel
Macron qui
conna à peine un an et
demi c'est normal
çaarrive faut pas rester debout après ça
il faut mettre une
chaise
[Applaudissements]
pas parie
pas
extraordinaire je sais chez vous vousez
dire c'est exceptionnelut la mettre tout
suite sur les réseau cette séquence les
gens des réseau sont toujours là sont
pas partis chez
eux pas d'aut
maisir remettez dans la longueur les TR
allez vousêes toujours au fournisseurs
de les renégocier et de le
faire je pense qu'il faut que vous
aidiez ce jeune homme alors ouvrez les
fenêtres ça arrive quand on a prenez un
bold à mon avis un sucre aussi et on
arrive ça c'est des jeunes qui prennent
pas le petit
déj je
dis à Paris à Marseille en Polynésie et
nous le
savons je pense qu'il faut
aider m'interrompre pour qu'il puisse y
avoir une intervention je vous rassure
c'est un malaise vagal ça ne devrait pas
être
grave a à peine un an et
demi c'est normal ça çaarrive qu'il faut
pas rester debout après ça il faut
mettre une
[Musique]
chaise merci d'être
avec38